dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here this is
one of those simulation papers where you
can look at it for three seconds and
immediately know what it's about
let's try that clearly expansion and
baking is happening and now let's look
inside mmm yep this is done clearly this
is a paper on simulating the process of
baking loving the idea so how
comprehensive is it well for a proper
baking procedure the simulator also has
to be able to deal with melting
solidification dehydration coloring and
much much more
this requires developing the proper
thermal mechanical model where these
materials are modeled as a collection of
solids water and gas
let's have a look at some more results
and we have to stop right here because
I'd like to tell you that the
information density when this
deceivingly simple scene is just
stunning in the x-axis from the left to
right we have a decreasing temperature
in the oven left being the hottest and
the chocolate chip cookies above our
simulated with an earlier work from 2014
the ones in the bottom row are made with
a new technique you can see a different
kind of shape change as we increase the
temperature if we crank the oven up even
more and look there even the chocolate
chips are melting oh my goodness what a
paper
talking about information density you
can also see here how they simulated
pieces of dough of different viscosities
react to different amounts of stress
viscosity means the amount of resistance
against deformation therefore as we go
up you can witness this kind of
resistance increasing
here you can see a cross-section of the
bread which shows the amount of heat
everywhere this not only teaches us why
crust forms on the outside layer but you
can see how the amount of heat diffuses
slowly into the inside this is a maxed
out paper by this I mean the execution
quality is through the roof and the
paper is considered done not when it
looks alright but when the idea is being
pushed to the limit and the work is as
good as it can be without trivial ways
to improve it and the results are
absolute witchcraft huge congratulations
to the authors in fact double
congratulations because it seems to me
that this is only the second paper of
mangu and ink
the lead author and it has been accepted
to the CAF Asia conference which is one
of the greatest achievements the
computer graphics researcher can dream
of a paper of such quality for the
second try Wow this episode has been
supported by weights and biases weights
and biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning
projects it can save you a ton of time
and money in these projects and is being
used by open AI Toyota Research Stanford
and Berkeley they have excellent
tutorial videos in this one the CEO
himself teaches you how to build your
own neural network and more make sure to
visit them through Wendy b.com slash
papers
waa nd b.com slash papers or just click
the link in the video description and
you can get a free demo today
our thanks to weights and biases for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time